welcome to my talk
um yeah so I will talk about closures in
Scala and how to avoid uh various safety
hazards when you use closures in
concurrent and distributed settings
mostly
um
before I start just a few words about my
own background
so I'm a faculty member at kth
um the the Royal Institute of Technology
in Stockholm Sweden
and before I joined kdh I was actually a
member of the scallop team for for about
nine years
and some of that time I spent at
typesafe which is now called light Bend
so you might know light Bend from you
know the development of various
Frameworks for distributed and
serverless computing
and uh yeah so in 2019 we were actually
uh humble to receive
um uh let's say the highest academic uh
recognition for programming languages
software
for the development of Scala
um and my own Focus has been
distributed and concurrent programming
so for example I created Scala actors
which was sort of the first widely used
actor library for Scala and that was
actually used in production at Twitter
and BBC and some some others and uh and
then I've been involved with various
efforts for concurrency in Scala so like
scala's futures
and also Escala async but um today
I want to talk about closures right
because closures are pretty essential
for much of what we do nowadays
and uh but you know there's a lot of
things that can go wrong if we use
closures in a concurrent or distributed
setting so I'm going to talk about some
of these things so that should be fun
um and and then I'm going to talk about
you know how to actually write safer
code that uses closures and um sort of
in the second part of my talk I'm going
to talk about a new library for Scala
called spores 3 that
um
yeah makes it let's say safer and also
more flexible to use closures in Scala
and I'm going to sort of dive into some
part of the implementation in particular
regarding serialization
yeah so let's dive in so first you know
what's a closure
um you've probably all used closures
before so I don't need to dwell too much
on it but I want to use this opportunity
to actually remind ourselves about the
sort of first and original definition of
what a closure is
which is quite nice so here in this
example right we're just creating a list
of numbers and we have this integer
threshold and then we're you know using
this filter combinator to you know
filter out all the numbers that are
below the threshold
and
of course this part in blue here is a
closure in Scala
and uh so this is Scala code and so for
this definition of what a closure is I'm
gonna of course assume you know lexical
scoping so you know I don't care about
you know dynamic name binding uh in this
talk so everything is assumed to be you
know lexically scoped right and so this
Anonymous function here in blue
right it it kind of
um refers to this threshold variable in
its lexical context right
um and this is of course fine because
you know that's the whole point of
closure is that we're able to do that
and um so now we you know with this we
can actually look at the original
definition of what a closure is which is
attributed to the late uh Peter Landon
I was a professor at Queen Mary
University and according to his
definition a closure right is an
anonymous function
that has some
called you know open bindings okay these
are essentially the three variables of
the closure and these open bindings have
been closed
by the lexical environment
okay so that's why it's called a closure
because we close the closure closes the
open bindings why is this an open
binding well because here we only have a
single binder for the num parameter
right threshold is not bound within this
Anonymous function instead you know we
close this open binding using the
lexical context where we essentially
look up you know what's here defined
earlier in the in the surrounding scope
and then
we essentially copy that value into the
environment of the closure so that when
the closer executes we can actually
access the the value right
so um
now we all know where this word closure
comes from and of course
closures are pretty essential to a lot
of tasks for example data processing so
here is an example using Apache Spark
which you may have used yourself right
so here we can essentially create
distributed data sets
in this case just you know from a simple
text file but then we can use
combinators like map and reduce
um you know to transform and reduce
these distributed data sets right so
using map for example you know we pass a
closer that is used to transform
a data set of lines into a data set of
integers which are the numbers the
numbers of words on each line right and
then we use reduce reduce to essentially
compute the the maximum number of words
on on any line in that file right and
these two blue things are again
enclosures right so
the code is just you know completely
based on based on closures
but of course we also use closures in
the setting of concurrent concurrency
right so this is now using Java for a
change right where we basically
have we're given a list of customers
and we want to
you know concurrently compute the
average age of this list of customers
and we essentially do that by creating a
task that we ship to a thread pool for
execution right and uh in this case you
know we Define this closure in blue
right and this closure yeah you know
takes this list of customers and it uses
the the Java stream API to you know
um you know transform this first to an
end stream using this get age method and
then you know computes the average and
returns that as a double okay and then
you know disclosure is converted to uh
to a Sam type callable
and that task is then submitted to an
Executor which is essentially a thread
pool that you know asynchronously
computes or like executes the closure
right but it immediately Returns the
future
um that we can use to you know uh access
the result when it comes in
okay so this is
um pretty common of course if you use
Futures in Scala you also use closures a
lot of times so this is
again quite common now
of course the issue is that there's lots
of ways in which things can go wrong if
you use closures in in these settings so
let's let's have a look at an example
right so here again we're using spark
where we take this toy array of integers
and we turn this into again a
distributed data set
called rdd in spark right it doesn't
really matter the details but you know
we turn this into this distributed data
set which you know in general you know
is distributed across a number of
executors
um so we can represent data that doesn't
fit in the into the memory of a single
machine right
and uh okay we have this sort of trivial
transform method
that we're now going to use
when we use the map combinator on this
distributed data set and basically we
want to transform the the data set such
that you know each element is mapped to
you know the result of transform of LM
right
um fine we just increment each integer
by one
and then of course at the end we just
you know collect everything uh on the
the driver node and print each uh print
each element
now this looks quite simple right that's
like probably one of the most the one of
the simplest programs you can write
using spark right
um but if you if you do that turns out
you know you actually get an exception
um which says you know task not
serializable
um that's a Pity fortunately you get
quite a bit more information nowadays
but I'm not going to show that uh just
for fun
um but essentially to understand this
error we need to look at this closure in
blue right
um again it's a very simple closure
um yet but why it's sort of tricky is
because we use it
um well for for this map method on
distributed data sets and like I
mentioned uh the student data set right
is sort of spread across a number of uh
worker or executor nodes
um and um to run map basically requires
that disclosure is serialized and sent
to each of these workers okay so we have
to be able to serialize this closure
okay well if you look at this closure it
uses you know this transform method that
seems reasonable but of course transform
is just short for this dot transform
right so actually
what this closure does is it captures
the this reference okay
now
if a closure captures something right
and we want to serialize the closure we
have to serialize everything that's
captured so we have to cap we have to
serialize the uh this reference
now what's the type of uh what's the
type of this well it's a spark example
right this enclosing class
but that's actually a Class Type that's
not serializable okay and that's
actually why we get this uh exception
right so we kind of accidentally capture
something that we maybe we're not aware
of
um that's not serializable
right so basically
um what is what this means is that you
know we cannot just use closures
um
as we're used to in a local or
sequential setting when we go to
distribution right it's a bit of a
safety risk
um and like I showed we can have runtime
exceptions like not serializable
exceptions on the jvm
and uh now I could also think about well
what about concurrency right and if you
just revisit this earlier example that I
showed you
um here we actually have a closure that
captures this customers
parameter right and uh well it turns out
as you probably all know lists in in
Java are actually mutable at least the
the default ones right and so that means
that this customer's list might actually
be mutated concurrently right because
um whoever calls this average age async
method
um could pass in a list that is mutated
concurrently with the the you know wild
disclosures being executed so here we
actually have a risk for data races
so also you know concurrency is can be
tricky right because we can easily get
data races
um if we execute closures on concurrent
threads
and these closures refer to Shared
mutable objects
anything else
well
um
there are of course a lot of scenarios
that we want to use closures in like for
example you know most applications or
many applications have a front end maybe
that runs on on a JavaScript engine and
a back end running on a jvm so
you know in some cases you might want to
actually send a closure from the front
end to the to the back end right just
like in spark you send closures you know
from the driver to all the executors so
this is a perfectly reasonable thing to
try to do but if you want to do that
well you actually need a portable
serialization scheme right you need to
be able to serialize something on the
JavaScript side that you can actually
deserialize on the on the jvm side and
well good luck doing that with the
closer
um right that's not just simply not
possible with closures out of the box
so
yeah
um if we look back at what I showed you
right these safety issues they actually
come from this unrestricted variable
capture right it's completely
unrestricted what we're allowed to do
so right in the case of concurrency
nobody prevents us from capturing
mutable shared objects right or in the
case of distribution we can easily
capture
uh you know objects that are not
serializable or they just that just
don't mesh well with distribution
so we can think of you know potential
remedies right where we could say well
how about we restrict the types of these
captured variables right so we could
kind of try to impose requirements that
okay you're only permitted to capture
types that are known to be serializable
or
we could also think of
you know providing or using different
modes for capture right capturing modes
so instead of just copying
a reference to a mutable object into the
closure we might think of maybe first
deeply cloning a mutable object
um before we we copy a reference to that
into the closure right so that the
closure has a well-defined you know
snapshot of the of the objects that it's
going to operate on
so there are
you know at least these kinds of things
you can think about
um and um yeah so
essentially you know if you want to spot
unsafe code
um we of course have to you know look at
the environment of of the closure of
closures right so all these it's it's
captured variables and there's of course
a bunch of let's say code smells right
so capturing a VAR which is in Scala a
reassignable variable that's usually uh
well probably not a good thing to do
especially not if you're using
concurrency or distribution
so especially if this thing is
reassigned in the body of the closure
now in Java you don't have this issue
because captured variables actually must
be final but as we've seen this does not
prevent you know this kind of uh these
kind of bugs that I showed you before in
in this um where we've used a future you
know or a callable that executed a
closure concurrently
then
um well we should think of you know we
should check the types of what we're
capturing so mutable types are can be an
issue
um and of course if we do distribution
you know uh there's a number of types
that just don't mesh well with that
um perhaps because they're not
serializable or because sorry about that
um
or because yeah they're just not they
cannot be used in a distributed setting
because remote executors might not be
able to access whatever the closure
needs okay
and
yeah
so um so the question is like how can we
write safer code and uh well of course
um the basics first right I mean first
of all we need to be able to spot you
know what are we actually capturing
um so our closers should obviously not
be too big I mean this applies to any
let's say method but probably especially
for
you know applies to closures and also we
should not capture too many variables I
suppose so if you you know capture 10
variables it's probably not a good idea
um but then yeah we have to sort of look
at the types of captured variables we
should of course let's say prefer
immutable types
immutable types are
probably in general preferable and
probably preaching to the choir here but
in the case of closures this is of
course especially interesting because
you know closures are created and
executed at different points in time so
immutable types make reasoning you know
much uh simpler
and then we should think about
any required properties right of the
capture types do they need to be
concurrency safe
um or or you know serializable and so
forth
um yeah but in general what we have to
check here is actually also the creation
of closures right what happens when you
create a closure
um
so essentially right the question is you
know what's the logical snapshot of the
memory that The Closer should be
initialized with right
because the closure only sees you know
the logical snapshot that is represented
by the the things that we're capturing
so for example
you know is it really sufficient that we
initialize the environment with the with
the copy of a reference or maybe we have
to you know clone a mutable object first
right so these are sort of important
questions and then of course the
semantics of the of the closure itself
it's pretty obvious that we need to look
at that
but um in a concurrent setting or
distributed setting of course we need to
see like do we need something like a
transactional semantics you know
um
for the application of the closure right
is it sort of a an atomic update of the
state of something and so on
so
excuse me so this is
these questions are not completely
trivial
and that's why I want to now like
introduce a new Scala Library which is
called spores 3. that tries to make it a
bit easier to you know create closure
using code that's actually can can be
very safe based on type checking and and
is also quite flexible
so
what is the goal right the goal is
essentially to provide an abstraction
that we can use actually as a drop-in
replacement for closures almost right
um and that like I said is sort of much
safer uh in especially concurrent and
distributed settings and uh has some
nice perks compared to regular closures
okay
so what we want to require right is
first of all we want to be able to you
know
um constrain the environment of our
closure like abstraction right so
somehow using uh using types we want to
express constraints on the captured
variables
then we want to support serialization
based on type classes
so
um I'm not going to explain what this
means really type classes if you've used
it before in fact if you use Scala
chances are very high that you've
actually used type classes but
essentially it's a way to
to look at compile time the the
serialization logic that's required to
serialize uh the the given types okay
and the advantage of that is that it's
um
very efficient and it's also safe
because you know we statically check
whether a serializer is available
um okay and plus we can make it portable
which is another Plus
in fact the whole like implementation of
this library is designed to be
completely portable from the beginning
right so Scala now has you know three
different back ends
um jvm JavaScript and Native okay the
native backend is still sort of beta but
um we want to have a portable solution
and also the implementation is designed
to be
you know relatively simple and uh quite
robust because you know we try to kind
of minimize the use of macros right so
macros is code that runs at compile time
that can also generate code and all
kinds of stuff
uh so
this can easily like complexity can
easily sort of uh go out of hand
and um so what's the idea the idea is
um it's called spores okay and this is
actually not a new idea in fact
um spores have been introduced a few
years ago
but in a research paper
by Heather Miller Mark nodersky and
yours truly right and um so it's not a
new thing
and uh what a sport is especially it's
essentially a special kind of closure
where the environment is explicit
okay
um so it's not sort of implicit that you
just refer to something you want to use
but you actually have to kind of make an
effort to you know include something in
the environment of a sport
and we also track the the type of the
environment in the type of the Spore
okay using uh type refinements in Scala
and this is quite powerful because we
can actually Express
um
constraints on the environment using
types and that's of course good because
you know Scala has a quite expressive
type system so we can we're able to
express various constraints I'm going to
show you some examples
and then finally of course we need to be
able to you know execute some operations
on on a sports environment for example
to to serialize it or to to duplicate a
Spore
right so then what's new in sports 3
right and that's essentially a
completely new implementation of spores
for Scala 3.
and uh you know it tries to address some
limitations that the original spores for
Scala 2 had so okay one one aspect is
that you know
um we try to limit the the use of macros
um to essentially compile time checks
okay so we're not doing a lot of code
generation because that you know caused
some issues with the earlier uh
implementation
and uh yeah like I mentioned Sports 3 is
designed to be portable portable from
the from the beginning
um
is the audio still yeah
um uh as a in contrast to spores for for
Scala Scala 2 okay so there was some
experimental efforts to you know support
spores on JavaScript but that was never
really uh released
and but perhaps what's most interesting
is that the sports 3 actually has a
quite interesting I think approach to
serialization
uh based on type classes and that's cool
because it's first of all it's flexible
so we can integrate this with various
serialization libraries of which there
are plenty as you know and but it's also
portable and we can sort of you know
enforce serializability
um statically so it's quite safe
so let me give you a quick overview of
spores so if you want to create a Spore
without an environment that's quite
simple right so we can simply pass a um
a function literal to a to the Spore
Factory
and in this case we actually have a
macro that checks that this function
literal does not capture anything okay
so this is if you would try to capture
something this would be rejected at
compile time
okay so this is a very well-behaved uh
you know Spore basically
and the type of this of such a simple
Spore is basically you know spore from
end to end so parameter type in result
type int and uh and then it has this
type refinement
uh where we basically have this type
member NF which is equal to nothing
um what does that mean well
so this sport doesn't capture anything
right so the environment there is no
environment and nothing is the uh is the
bottom type in Scala so it's a subtype
of all other types and in fact there's
no variable that has type nothing and so
that's very fitting because if you would
try to read the environment of that
Spore there would there's nothing that
we could give there right so the only
thing we can do is throw an exception
right and so the type nothing makes a
lot of sense here
um sport types are also subtypes of the
corresponding function types right so
Spore T comma R extends uh T Arrow R and
of course it's uh contravariant in the
parameter type in covariant in the
return type
and uh yeah we have this type member and
here in this definition it's abstract
right because it's sort of only uh set
when we create a concrete Spore and uh
well of course this thing needs to be
sealed because
um first to for this to be safe uh we
cannot allow user code to to extend to
extend that trade
right so let's look at some more
interesting things it's like spores with
environments right and in this case
um we need to again because the
environment is explicit we need to kind
of explicitly initialize the environment
so let's say we have this variable Str
that should be captured by the Spore so
that it can be used within that within
the Spore
so to be able to do that we need to pass
it as a as an argument to the
um to the Spore Factory
and then you know the body of the Spore
now has this additional parameter
n okay you can call it whatever you want
but um the first parameter is
um the the environment of the Spore
so that you know in the body we can we
can use it right
um okay and now if you do that this type
this Spore has a different type right
it's uh sport end to end you know but
this type member is equal to string
right because the environment is you
know consists of a single string
all right so now first question you
might have is well why do we do we
really want to use this extra parameter
for the environment that seems rather
you know clunky and well
sure user code needs another parameter
but it's also quite nice because we can
actually use pattern matching
um when we access the environment right
so let's say you want to capture two
things
the way it works is we pass these again
we have to initialize the environment
explicitly right so we pass them in as a
tuple
and and then we we immediately use
pattern matching to you know destructure
on the the environment okay
so this is actually quite nice if we you
know if the environment consists of
multiple multiple variables okay and
this is possible because you know the
environment is the first parameter so we
can easily use pattern matching there
okay now but what's more interesting is
actually these type-based constraints
um so
essentially since we have this type
member we can actually express some
constraints on the environment and for
this we would typically use context
parameters
or you know in Scala 2 they were called
implicit parameters right so for example
let's say we have a method that takes a
Spore
and it wants to to constrain the
environment so that we can only capture
thread safe types right so here's an
example so let's say we have this future
method
um that takes a Spore which is uh
essentially a sunk right so it takes
unit and returns t
and um
well this method is supposed to you know
spawn a you know concurrent computation
that executes the Spore and immediately
returns a future of t
but now of course we want to say that
well for safety right
um whatever the environment of the Spore
is it should be thread safe right it
should not access shared mutable objects
right no should be threat safe and so we
can use a context parameter to constrain
the environment type right so we can
actually select this end type member
from the Spore s to say well we need to
have a an instance of this type class
thread save okay for this type S dot m
right and and you can imagine so the
threat safe is not actually part of the
Scala standard library but you can
imagine that you know this is a type
class that we can uh Define where
essentially there's an instance for for
all the threat safe types like all The
Primitives you know all the like
immutable types and and also things like
concurrent hash maps and so on right
these could all be these could all have
instances of that type class
right and so if you would capture one of
these uh things that would be accepted
um but if there is no
instance of that type class at compile
time right then calling this method
would be disallowed right so we could
not call this method
um with such a Spore
right and
so this is really quite powerful so this
lets us express things uh a bit similar
to sendable closures in in Swift for
instance right and I'm going to use the
same trick actually later on when we
talk about safe serialization
right so yeah let's talk about
serialization right
um because I already mentioned
what we want to have is kind of a
flexible way to serialize closures so we
want to be able to integrate with
various Frameworks
because as you know there are many of
those right and uh so yeah we need to
integrate with different ones
we also want to have a portable way so
that we can support what I mentioned
earlier right this scenario where we can
send closures between
between uh you know machines running on
different back-ends essentially
and also we want things to be safe so
you know whether a Spore is serializable
or not should be determined statically
right so that we avoid this these issues
we saw earlier with uh in spark for
instance okay now there are some
assumptions we need
um
first
um yeah serialization is supposed to be
used mainly for communication between
remote machines
so we're not going to use it for data
persistence let's say
um and also one assumption is that every
node is actually running the same code
you know um this might sound like a
strict uh requirement but turns out you
know these Frameworks like Apache spark
and Flink and and and so they they
actually have that requirement as well
so this is not such a big deal in the
end so this is a quite common uh common
assumption
then finally we don't want to transmit
any bytecode or source code for security
right what's the approach
um well instead of serializing the code
we don't want to send code we serialize
a unique identifier that lets us
instantiate the implementation of that
Spore and of course the environment of
the Spore
so in practice what we do is we create a
named Spore Builder that lets us
instantiate the implementation of a
Spore
and then yeah we can serialize the fully
qualified name of that Builder so here's
an example so here we create a builder
Spore Builder which has the types of the
environment and of parameter and return
type and it has the implementation of
the Spore right
um and uh
and then we can using the this Builder
we can create a serializable
representation called Spore data which
takes uh a sport Builder and the
environment of the Spore okay and then
we can actually
serialize this Spore data as usual right
in this case using micro pickle
um
uh yeah nothing special here and then we
might get out some Json like that where
we have the fully qualified name of the
Builder and the environment
right but what I want to talk about is
actually the safe serialization right so
let's say we want to write a method send
off that supposed to serialize a Spore
and send it you know across the network
how do we do that and how do we ensure
the safety of that
well
um what we can do is use the Spore data
which is a serializable representation
which has exactly the same structure as
the sport type so it has this type
member for the environment
and in this case we actually leave the
environment type polymorphic right we
abstract from that and um and S is just
a type parameter which has that sport
data as it's upper bound
and this is just to as a shorthand
and then you know this is the the
parameters board data of Type S and then
we can again use the context parameter
to enforce that there's a type class
instance for Type S called read writer
which is essentially the serializer for
that type okay
in Scala we can also abbreviate this
with so-called context bound okay which
says that for this type S we need to
have an instance of that type class okay
and this actually now means it's checked
at compile time whether the Spore is
serializable because its environment is
realizable
I'm going to skip over that because I
see I'm running a bit late here in on
time so
um just a few words about how we
Implement serialization so like I
mentioned we have the Spore Builder that
you know we used to to find the
implementation of this war
and um what's really cool is actually
how we look up the serializer and
deserializer and we do that when the
Builder is constructed so
the The Constructor of the Builder right
takes of course these type arguments but
also takes the the body of the of the
Spore which is here right and but it
also has this context parameter so at
compile time this is resolved right so
we look up the read writer for Type e
and and then it's available you know in
the body of this of the Builder and this
is really awesome because at the point
when we actually want to create a Spore
like in memory
but we still have the environment in
serialized form in this case as a string
right we can we can actually deserialize
the environment because we have the read
writer in scope
um for Type e so we can actually
deserialize the environment uh like
using a type specific
um deserializer okay so I think this is
really cool
um yeah then finally
um the sport data actually what we do
here is we actually check that the
Builder is a top level Singleton object
that has you know a fully qualified name
that we can look up on different nodes
in our Network and we also look up the
fully qualified name like at compile
time so we don't need to use reflection
for that
and then we can of course serialize that
yeah I'm just going to go a bit fast
here so the implementation is open
source under Apache 2 license like I
said
Scala jvm and scholar.js is supported
and we plan to support Scala native very
soon now right and
um yeah integration with you pickle is
sort of provided out of the box and we
plan to do more
yeah summary so
like I said distribution and concurrency
kind of pose some safety uh risks when
we use closures
if you want to do things in a safer way
we have to consider
captured variables their types and the
capturing semantics and this is made
easier using spores 3 right which is
essentially a new implementation of the
the spores idea but for Scala 3. and um
yeah Sports have an explicit environment
that we track using type refinements you
can express type-based constraints to
make things statically safe
and we have a way to serialize spores
that's you know quite flexible portable
and also statically safe
with this uh thanks very much and
unfortunately this we're sort of out of
time so if you have questions you know
just find me afterwards yeah thanks
again
[Applause]